[Music]
so
good morning everybody seven o'clock in
the uk sleaze and unease over mandatory
kobe chaps for nhs staff and a train to
glasgow to save the planet the prime
minister has a lot on his plate today
we'll be putting all of that to the
health secretary sajid javid in just a
moment labour's chris bryant the chair
of the parliamentary standards committee
is also on the programme we'll also get
a picture of covic cases around the
world from the world health
organization's david nabarro of course
and he was one of the most notorious
murder trials in recent history we'll be
live in south africa to find out why the
former paralympian oscar pistorius could
be granted parole after his conviction
for killing his girlfriend riverstein
camp and
more on this as well talking to british
zoo officials as scientists say kovid 19
could be spreading from humans to
animals following an outbreak at denver
zoo in the united states
with those guys it's wednesday the 10th
of november
no jab no job what next for the tens of
thousands of nhs staff in england who've
been told to get the kobe vaccine to
work in the health service
labour calls on the anti-sleaze watchdog
to investigate sir jeffrey cox over
claims he misused his parliamentary
office to carry out legal work
roadblock climate blow for the prime
minister as the world's two largest car
manufacturers swerve a global deal to
cut new car emissions by 2040
and here in chennai it's red
as the city prepares for more extreme
rain and it's already looking like this
duke of sussex claims he warned the boss
of twitter that the social media giant
was allowing a coup to be staged just
hours before protesters stormed the u.s
capitol building
i warned him that his platform was
allowing a crew to be staged that email
was sent the day before and then it
happened and i haven't heard them since
wall of lava the volcanic eruption in la
palma continues its destruction of
thousands of acres of land
[Music]
good morning everybody there's a lot on
the prime minister's plate this morning
the fallout over the news that frontline
nhs staff will have to get a kovid jab
to keep their job from april plus
reports now of labour calling for an
investigation over claims the former
cabinet minister sir jeffrey cox broke
the rules by using his parliamentary
office for his second job offering legal
advice
all that as he's preparing to dash to
glasgow today to pull out all the stops
he says to save the planet we'll be
joined by the health secretary satya
javid in just a moment first let's take
you through how this morning's
newspapers are covering the news on
kovid vaccines here we go starting with
the mirror um saying around a hundred
thousand nhs staff face losing their
jobs unless they get fully vaccinated by
april
the eye warns care homes in birmingham
manchester and also nottingham could see
staff shortages when mandatory
vaccinations are introduced because
uptake among the profession in those
areas is low the express also lead with
the health secretary's ultimatum to
health care workers adding 73 000 could
quit over the plans
speaking to the health secretary about
all of that in just a second not just
prime minister with a lot on his plate
today no the no jab no job policy has
been thought about for some time there's
been a long consultation that the
government have held and sajid javid
said that there were strong arguments on
both sides but he told mps in the
commons yesterday the balance tips to
one side which is that protecting
patients who are in hospital from covid
is the priority and therefore those
staff who do not get vaccinated will be
redeployed or asked to leave if they are
on the nhs front line working with
patients now mindful that the winter is
the most pressurized period for the
health service he intends to bring this
in from the first of april next year so
there are some months to go and of
course it will have to be voted on in
parliament where labour do not support
it and i expect there will be some
conservative opposition as well so there
are some months to go but of course the
policy for care home staff to have
mandatory vaccinations comes in tomorrow
we know that something like 32 000 care
home staff have not been vaccinated and
many of them have already been asked to
leave their jobs and as far as the pm's
concern learned is less on no private
jets up to glasgow today yes he is in
glasgow bit earlier than expected today
he'll be getting the train back unlike
last time why is he there because a deal
needs to be reached by the end of this
week this is the crunch period where the
negotiators are speaking to their
political leaders so especially those
countries like china who haven't sent
their president those negotiating teams
will be speaking to the politicians back
home about what their commitments are
going to be and boris johnson says this
isn't about any one country this is
about everybody making the commitments
now because of course the whole point of
this summit is to try and limit global
temperature rises to one and a half
degrees by the end of this century but
we heard yesterday from climate
scientists that we're well off track
might even reach two and a half degrees
by the end of the century so the prime
minister wants to get some more
commitments by the end of the week to
prevent this
a good deal at this summit really
slipping through his fingers yeah and
we're not really sure at this stage
whether it's going to go on for an extra
day or not it certainly will if it means
that there might be a deal in the office
almost always at these summits i've been
to two of them before ends up being
middle of the night on the day after
what was supposed to be on the last day
we understand a draft deal has just been
published today by the un and then all
the countries will be looking at that
with a view to doing some more wrangling
before the end okay um tomorrow i know
you're going to chat to us again once
we've heard from sergey javid we're
looking for him not sure where he is
we'll sign in hoping
thanks very much indeed uh while we're
looking for the health secretary let me
tell you what the prime minister is up
to heading to scotland as we heard there
from tomorrow it's been revealed some of
the world's largest car manufacturers
won't be signing a global deal to phase
out petrol and diesel cars how
interesting today ministers from 24
countries and car manufacturers
including ford mercedes and volvo are
expected to commit to 100 zero emissions
new cars and van sales by 2040 but the
world's two largest manufacturers that's
a volkswagen and toyota they're among
those that have declined to sign up the
uk government will reaffirm its
commitment to outlawing the scale and
the sale of new internal combustion
engine vehicles by 2030 and will also
commit to making all hgvs zero emission
by 2040.
well
the future of transport is the main
issue being discussed at the glasgow
summit today the u.s transport secretary
has told sky news america will do
everything it can to try to reach a deal
on making travel cleaner
knowing that transportation is the
single biggest sector in our economy
creating greenhouse gas emissions we
view that as a challenge and an
obligation and an opportunity to be a
big part of the solution on the surface
side that means everything from
deploying more electric vehicles and
electric vehicle chargers to making sure
that active transportation in our cities
and small communities is supported but
also with the historic legislation that
just passed our congress a level of
investment in public transit like we've
never done as a country before
ashna is with us now up at uh cop 26 in
glasgow we're looking everywhere for
that minister we've no idea where he is
but we'll find him ashna in the meantime
bad news about toyota and is it
volkswagen as well
yeah that's right okay so i mean the
government's meant to be announcing a
huge new emissions deal today all about
electric cars all about the future of
heavy goods vehicles being um
electric for the next in the next couple
of decades but they have been some two
big car manufacturers some of the
largest manufacturers who have refused
to sign this deal it's meant to be the
case that it could come into force in
2035 maybe even 2040s but it looks as
though volkswagen and toyota the world's
two largest manufacturers are among
those that declined to sign this new
route zero uh pledge which is due to be
announced later today by the prime
minister's tomorrow was saying it is a
huge deal for uh negotiators today but
also delegates as well as the prime
minister of the if the uk
comes to cop this is a real moment this
is about adding a political heavyweight
into all these negotiations as tomorrow
is saying a lot of these countries have
spent the last few days now debating
with each other negotiating terms of
this new pledge new contract this new
agreement that we might get by the end
of the week but it could well be that
they now have to go on the phone
physically pick up the phone and
convince their leaders that this might
be a good way to go down and the point
of the prime minister being here today
is to encourage more ambition more
ambitious pledges from these nations who
are might be a little bit reticent about
movement on where to go but it all comes
as analysts and scientists predicting
that the pledges and the commitments
made so far would only get us so far
it's only going to get us to 2.4 degrees
of world warming and that's a huge limit
that would that would mean so much more
extreme weather and what we want to do
is limit it to 1.5 degrees so it's hoped
that this injection of this political
heft will get some more movement on new
pledges and as tomorrow touched on we
might well be seeing a first draft of
this communique by the united nations
today okay thanks so much indeed
katarina's actually in chennai for us
talking of extreme weather good morning
to you uh katarina my goodness that went
that uh flood water's not gone down much
has it if at all
no it hasn't and in fact it has
continued to rise just we've had a very
heavy bout of rain in the last hour or
so and i don't know if you
can see behind me we arrived at this
road maybe an hour and a half ago and
it's gone up at least two inches
it's now a case of really preparing for
what more might come down we're hearing
there is going to be a forecast or there
is a forecast of more extreme rain today
and tomorrow uh we've just been speaking
with these guys here and they tell us
that their restaurant here wow i mean
you can see it's already
moments from looking like it's getting
underneath that barrel they tell us
actually inside there's already rain in
there people clawing to get their
vehicles on any bit of higher ground
we've seen people that live in this
residential neighborhood they've already
been moving their vehicles it looks like
the person that owns this car
doesn't have long
to move before that gets flooded
this rain started on sunday when 20
centimeters fell within an hour and
low-lying parts of the city like we're
in now have struggled to shift it there
is just so there's been so much building
over the last 10 years and there has
been a lot of anger towards state
ministers that they've not done enough
since the last time tonight flooded
which was about five years ago to make
it more resilient to extreme weather to
extreme rainfall so that when there is
unprecedented volumes of rain like we
had on sunday like we're expecting later
on today and thursday they don't have to
do things like this put in road barriers
so that people can't get down roads that
are now totally waterlogged there's
pumping going on
there are emergency teams in some part
of the city and the greater suburb that
are already looking at evacuating people
out of their houses we know from
sunday's flooding that there were many
neighborhoods where homes were totally
inundated and this is the problem look
even in that short walk we've done is
the water level changes so quickly so
one house can be dry but a neighbor's
house might not be and that is the
difficulty for teams as they're going
around trying to assess
what to do who to help first because
this is a city of 20 million people and
everyone is preparing for the worst
i'm just going to take you sorry it's
quite
slow going wading through this water
it's quite challenging
i'm going to take you to the main road
because as you can see there are still
people trying to get through this
flooding
schools have been shut the past two days
they're shut again today they'll be
closed again tomorrow
but government offices also shut but
private businesses still trying to get
through
look at how many people are still out on
the road
we've seen people trying to move their
vehicles to get them onto some sort of
higher ground obviously we don't know
if that's the case here people have been
advised to stay off the roads it's just
too dangerous when they don't know
exactly what's underneath i can't see
what's in front of them
and the water logging is making it
very very difficult for anyone to get
anywhere
there are of course
many concerns about safety of people in
their homes in this part of the town
this is one
of
the wealthiest neighborhoods in chennai
most of the houses you see here are
actually apartment blocks the people are
elevated they're higher up
but towards the outskirts people are
living more in bungalows in small houses
that are much more prone to this sort of
severe flooding
and as i said those rescue teams they're
going out they're doing recce they're
assessing now because this isn't the
worst of it everyone is preparing for
much more intense rain
wednesday and thursday
people are trying
to rescue what they can from their homes
get their vehicles onto higher ground
and as we saw
you know businesses are already shutting
up but really you look around you
there's no sandbags there's no
protection for businesses
there's really nothing to stop the water
coming in if it comes down as is
forecast and it continues to rise like
we're seeing it and as the guy we were
speaking to over there said to us it's
just more money he has to spend
it makes people obviously the business
is shut they're losing money through
that they just want there to be a better
plan and more resilient so that when
there is extreme rainfall like this the
city is just better able to cope
serena just before i let you go i mean
it is rain water that you're talking
about but it's causing problems with the
sewage system as well people are walking
around in this they're not going to be
very well are they
no absolutely not after so many days of
this area being flooded it's what now
nearly 72 hours
the rain waters mixed with drain water
inevitably and it's very unpleasant it
smells really bad and as you say you
know we're here in our protective rain
gear but just i mean just spin around
dude who's been around there you know
there are guys still in tuk tuks
these
moped vehicles
they're wearing sandals the water's not
far from going into vehicles like this
and as you say
whenever there is flooding of this sort
of level it brings
disease
it brings so many issues
obviously
in some parts of the town in some parts
of the city we're told that power has
already been cut off
so that if there are any loose wires
that are dangling in to this water it
doesn't cause any safety concerns but of
course this is an enormous city it's one
of the biggest in india
how can you ensure
that everywhere is going to be safe it's
exceptionally difficult it's very very
challenging there's been a lot of
criticism already for the state ministry
as i say for not better preparing you
know they've had instances like this
before yes the volume of rain that fell
on sunday
is unprecedented it's not usual but
still they are used to monsoon rain to
city that is used to
flooding it needs the monsoon rain to
make sure that farmers can guarantee a
crop for the next year but what they
need to do is find that balance between
you know rain which is helpful and then
rain which just does this i mean it's
really incredible i think when you see
people still trying to move through it
but it's going to get to a point where
the city simply grinds to a whole if
they continue to see rain fall like it
has over
as it fell on sunday and as they're
predicting it to fall today and tomorrow
okay lovely thanks very much indeed for
the update um keep well katarina thank
you especially with that horrible dirty
water that you're wading through there
thanks a lot
uh one of my old bosses always used to
say to me uh viewers will forgive you
every anything as long as you're honest
with them
in the interest of full transparency
we think sanji javi got lost but we
think we know where he is and we think
he's going to be on the program in a
minute or two so uh stay tuned for more
on that he's up at cop 26 in glasgow
also still to come uh dr david navarro
will be uh with us uh from the world
health organization he's giving us his
very latest assessment of the global
fight against covid19
and uh for the latest on the fight
against flu and kobe 19 in the uk we'll
chat with dr david lloyd our regular gp
of course
and more than a quarter of a million
afghan refugees have now fled to iran
we'll talk to the secretary general of
the norwegian refugee council jan
egerland
live from tehran very shortly
uh latest on the covert data for the uk
has recorded 33 117 new cases that have
been sadly uh 262 new deaths uh bringing
the total number of deaths reported
within 28 days of a positive test to
more than
142 000.
559 people received their first dose of
a vaccine in the last day while the
number of people receiving their second
dose was 20 000.
almost 46 million people have now had
two doses of the vaccine
we found him he's here hello health
secretary
hi there good morning lovely to join you
from glasgow
excellent we lost you but thankfully
you're with us now which is great talk
to us about compulsory jobs i'm trying
to find my way around
[Laughter]
well i'm glad that you phoned us now
we've been we were waiting for you we'll
always make room for you sir compulsory
jobs for nhs staff why
because first of all let me just thank
nhs and care staff for the amazing work
they do but especially those that have
already chosen uh to take that vaccine
and they've done that not only to
protect themselves and their colleagues
but most of all they've taken it to
protect their patients and and that's
why that's really at the heart of this
this is about a patient's safety we know
that the vaccines work we also know that
patients in hospital in care these are
some of the most vulnerable people in
our society and if they are exposed to
covert it could be fatal and i think
it's our duty to make sure that they are
safe as they can be and that's why i
announced this yesterday so that from
april next year that if you work in nhs
or care you will be required to be
vaccinated and i want this to be a
positive decision for for everyone and
and to work with them there will be
absolutely no scapegoating no singling
out no shaming but working with
colleagues to support them in every way
that we can to help them make this
positive decision so they can protect
themselves their colleagues and most of
all their patients yeah but should they
lose their job if they don't want to
i don't want to see anyone lose their
job i don't want to see anyone have to
walk away from their job but i think
that what we all do want to see we want
to see our hospitals people providing
care whether it's in your home in our
care home and we want those patients
those people to be as safe as possible
and now with what we know about this
this horrid virus and
but also that the fact that the vaccines
work i just do think it is important to
be doing everything we can because also
what i don't want to see most of all
what i don't want to see is someone
being exposed to
that's vulnerable being exposed to covid
when it could have been prevented and
perhaps they might even die from that
and i think that would be totally
unacceptable
so if you've been double jabbed then you
can't pass on the virus
no if you've been double jab then you're
less likely to be infected of course you
can still get infected but you're less
likely to and we know that so if you've
had the az jab for instance that we know
that from study after study the the the
the chances of you being affected are 65
less than they would be otherwise uh the
with the fisa jab it's about 80 less
you're less likely to be infected and if
you are uh you know you can only pass on
the virus if you are infected and and
that's why the the vaccines are so
important
yeah but you've got a 37 chance of still
passing on covid19 if you've got it even
if you've been double jabbed
and you know this isn't about perfection
you know what there's no it's not really
an infection that we can with jesus
health secretary come on
we don't live in a risk-free world this
this virus we're learning about it all
the time and it's our duty to make sure
that we're doing everything we can
using all the tools that we have to
protect people and what yesterday's
announcement is about is about
protecting some of the most vulnerable
people in our society that we already
know anyone who's in hospital in a
hospital bed they're there because
they're vulnerable they're already ill
there's already some something that's
making them you're ill and vulnerable
and the last thing you want to do is
expose them to this horrible virus if it
can be prevented now i'm not pretending
nobody is that you can have a 100
100 method of of protecting them but
what you can do is reduce the the
chances of them becoming affected and i
think it is perfectly reasonable to say
to everyone that works in health and
care to to that you please you take this
vaccine some 93
have had at least one shot and that's
fantastic to see there's still around
100 000 we estimate in the nhs that have
not but over the coming months we will
work with them the nhs will work with
them in the most positive constructive
way to help them make that positive
decision to take the vaccine yeah 37
chance is still pretty high though um
isn't it would it not be better well
would you what would you like okay would
you like a hundred percent chance yeah
you're welcome
to go on if i may
37 it's 37 chance you say you say it's
quite high but i'll tell you what 80 and
90 chance is a lot higher and i think
your viewers listening to this program
would understand that that this is about
minimizing the risk it's about
minimizing the risk with this virus it's
a horrid virus we sadly we know so many
people that have been affected you may
know i know people i've lost loved ones
to this but lots of people have
listening to this program and i think
what they would expect that if you are
in a vulnerable situation if you're in a
hospital bed you're in a care home
you're at your home receiving
domiciliary care they don't want to know
that that
that care worker that is perhaps
visiting some 10 people that day if they
are
infected perhaps they're asymptomatic do
you want them going around every house
and infecting 10 of their people that
they're sitting them of course you don't
your viewers don't want to see that now
i'm not saying it can be a hundred
percent i can jump in at some stage and
say i was going to go on away why you
can but i'm only doing what you normally
do but carry on
if i may uh i was going to say why not
test somebody every day if they're a
frontline worker and then you're a
hundred percent sure that they haven't
got the virus
we do that anyway the nhs will will do
that in most i don't know
exactly every day but in the nhs and in
care homes people will be tested
regularly precisely for the reason that
you pointed out earlier that when you
take vaccines of course your chance of
being infectious is a lot less but it's
not foolproof and that's why having the
vaccine alongside regular testing is
that is the best way that we can go and
protect everyone in any way that we can
you test people twice a week i believe
in the nhs why not test them every day
i think that's it's about regular
testing and i'd leave that up to the
clintons
i should i i think the clinicians should
decide how often people need to be
tested and and the types of tests that
are taken but if i think as long as
there is regular testing and people have
taken the vaccine and of course there
are other controls in place in the
hospital the infection controls and
measures i think all these taken
together makes the conditions for those
vulnerable people as safe as they
possibly can be and again that's really
at the heart of yesterday's announcement
it's all about patient safety of course
it will help protect other colleagues in
the nhs and care as well because you
know you don't want the staff to to get
ill if that can be avoided and so
this is what yesterday's announcement is
about
okay what has jeffrey cox done wrong
well i don't want to get into any
individual case especially if i don't
know the details but i i know obviously
the the big issue that you're talking
about i do think it is important that
you're any member of parliament if they
do have any external duties that they
are completely open and transparent
about that i think it is uh important
that their constituents obviously know
about that and also that they engage in
no kind of lobbying whatsoever
okay labour's referring to jeffrey cox
to the standards committee for a brazen
beat breach of the rules do you want to
defend him this morning
as i said i'm not going to get into an
individual case i don't know the
individual circumstances of every member
of parliament uh all i can say about
jeffrey cox is my time in in government
with him when he was beside me as a
cabinet minister he was a fantastic
cabinet minister but in terms of
these issues i don't know the details
okay let me ask you more generally then
do you feel comfortable with the rules
as they presently stand on mps having
second jobs
i i think the rules as they currently
are in terms of having that flexibility
whether it's a a consultancy type job
whether it's perhaps it's an mp that is
still serving in some capacity as a
doctor a nurse or you know i think it's
it's a right that those rules allow that
flexibility but i think the most
important thing really is is that
that mp whoever he or she may be is
completely transparent and open follows
all the rules and that they're so that
their constituents and and the wider
public know uh that they might have
another interest but also i think it's
important that they continue to spend
the vast majority of their time on their
parliamentary affairs and their
constituency affairs okay should um
should mps be able to use their office
for uh second job work
no
okay so if they did
what should happen to them
well that's that i i again i
you might be trying to draw me into some
individual case but if if there are
your concerns or you said no there
should be someone believes if someone
believes for a good reason that they
might then i think what they should do
is ask the appropriate authorities to
look into it and they can get down to
the facts yeah but of course you
shouldn't be using whether it's your
parliamentary office
yeah if it's if it's your
if it's your uh whether it's your
parliamentary office or any other
parliamentary stationery or anything
that's funded or supported by the
taxpayer of course that should not uh be
used and and again i i can't talk about
any individual case i think the rules on
on the use of whether it's parliamentary
property or or or your letters or
letterheads or stamps or anything like
that i think the rules are clear and of
course all mps would be expected to
observe that at all times
okay i'm not talking about specific
cases because you don't want to
but if somebody did use their office for
a second job what should happen to them
no i i don't know the it will depend on
all the circumstances and i i'm not the
judge of this nor should i be it should
be independently judged by the
parliamentary standards commissioner so
if there are particular cases then i
would trust the commissioner to look at
that and come to the right decision
um okay well that's that's what jeffrey
cox did apparently but you don't want to
talk about specific cases what i can um
talk to you about though is that the
vice chairman andrew barry of the um
conservative party has stepped down and
he says he can't uh can't cope with all
this sleaze anymore it doesn't look
great does it when that sort of thing
happens
i don't know about that you just share
that information with me but i think
look it's really important that that
parliamentarians whether whichever party
that they're in uh that they are very
clear transparent rules whether it's
around lobbying it's the use of
parliamentary uh property and that they
are held to the very highest of
standards
it's frustrating for you though i'm sure
isn't it given that if
last week um the prime minister had not
forced all of you to support his mate
who subsequently had to step down
because the british public are just not
having it anymore then you know we
wouldn't be in you wouldn't be in this
position would you
as a party
that there's there was a case a
particular case in that case it was the
owen patterson case and uh i i voted for
that motion i do regret it because i
think it was wronger for me to conflate
the owen patterson case with the right
of an appeal i do think it's important
to for for parliamentarians and a
cross-party bases to to think about how
they might always be able to improve a
system but it was wrong to conflate it
with owen patterson so i regret having
voted for that i'm glad it's been uh
something that is settled now as in i
believe yesterday the government has
brought forward a motion to rescind that
and to accept the owen patterson report
in full and i think that's the right
thing
okay final uh question before i let you
go back to uh on topic for you i'm
reading in the newspaper this morning
that um over 65s in france
will not be allowed access to um
restaurants on trains etc unless they've
had their booster is that something that
you might look at
we're not looking at that yet we are
you're very focused on our booster
program as you would imagine over 10.6
million boosts i think uh throughout the
uk so far already a record number of
bookings many people coming forward i
think in due course uh we will have to
to to look at you know what constitutes
vaccination but at this point uh the
most important thing is that anyone
that's eligible gets out there and gets
their boost okay you said yet so
potentially in the future
i can't i can't rule that out and uh i
think that we know
now that the vaccines do wane and is
important that uh that those vaccines
where it's necessary that those people
get a top up and that's what the booster
program
is about but i think it's something that
we have to keep under review
okay that was a bit spikey of us both
today wasn't it um i don't know what's
going to happen in your next video but i
must let you go you you like spikey
i do actually it's because i'm a wigan
street fighter it's good to talk to you
thanks very much indeed for joining us
thank you goodbye bye bye
oh he had three weetabix this morning
dinner david nabarro is joining us from
the world health organization hello to
mr dr navarro forgive me good morning
lovely to see you um
over 65 should be forced to have a job
what do you think
yes i i was listening to your
interaction with the uk
minister and i thought
what a tough job he has because on the
one hand
you do want to try to get as many people
as possible protected if you're relying
on vaccines primarily to get this
pandemic under control but at the same
time
there are a lot of people who for
genuine reasons don't want to be
vaccinated and it creates a terrible
conundrum for you so yes i know i know
about the the shifting rules in in
france and the change in the structure
of the sanitary past as it's called
and
i just hope that governments can achieve
their objectives without putting really
tough requirements onto people that then
will turn them against their governments
because
this is going to go on for for years
this this covered pandemic it's not
going to suddenly stop i i hope it does
but i don't think it will and we all
need to be able to uh tolerate and
cooperate
with each other without actually having
to have uh rigid instructions or what's
called these vaccine mandates like you
were just discussing so i'm gonna stay
absolutely on the fence on this and say
please please don't get to the point
where you have to put really tough tough
restrictions that just make people feel
really frustrated because we've got to
do this in partnership
doesn't sound as though you're sitting
on the fence doctor if i'm honest it
sounds as though you're suggesting that
people shouldn't be forced to have a job
within the world health organization
we've generally said
don't force people and but at the same
time
we've also said that we can't
take on government policy on behalf of
individual governments and uh we do
recognize that each government has to
try to work out what's right in their
own circumstance that is it it's sitting
on the fence i suppose but yes
i'm going to tell you that i personally
i'm really trying my best to to to get
across to people that forcing folk into
particular positions uh through various
uh coercive measures is a really last
resort i mean when i've done any
infectious disease control effort the
thing that i've learned
is that people are the solution they're
not the problem and so therefore
partnership between government and
people is critical it's really difficult
when then
issues get split along party lines and
and cooperation gets so much harder and
perhaps that's the toughest thing about
kobe is that the responses get
politicized in some places if you wear a
mask you're thought to belong to a
particular political party and that's
the most regretful thing about the
present situation uh we've all need to
be able to do what we've got to do uh
regardless of what politics we we adopt
what more should we we be doing in the
uk to try to um stem uh covid 19 and its
transmission we saw our prime minister
in a hospital um earlier this week and
he didn't have a mask on he doesn't have
to wear it in a corridor he just uh and
this was a corridor where he was meeting
people he just you just need to wear a
mask in a clinical setting but we've
spoken previously about how important it
is to to wear a mask do you still abide
by that
i'm not sitting on the fence on this one
okay
where you've got
large amounts of virus being transmitted
everybody should do everything to avoid
either getting the virus or
inadvertently passing it on and we know
that wearing a face mask reduces the
risk we know that maintaining physical
distance reduces the risk we know that
hygiene regular hand washing and
coughing into the uh
on into your elbow reduces the risk we
should do it all and if we should not
rely on any one
intervention like vaccination on its own
so yes yes yes please would every leader
be wearing face masks particularly when
in indoor settings and could everybody
please be face masks if they possibly
can when they're up close and personal
with other people and especially in
non-ventilated environments this virus
is unforgiving and we need to do
everything possible to prevent it
getting in between us and affecting us
um and what as far as travel is
concerned we know that we can fly to the
united states again as of um yesterday
you're going to be flying here to see
those lovely grandchildren anytime soon
well i did go and see my grandchildren
over the weekend and uh i said to otto
who's the one that we've discussed a few
times that uh he's often discussed
between us he didn't exactly reply
because he's not talking yet
i got a picture but i i don't think i'll
waste your time trying to show you but
he's in very very form
yeah too difficult but i have to say
okay that
i have to say
that
i'm not traveling very much
why am i not traveling very much because
i don't want to get covered
i'm in the wrong age group and i've got
all the uh adverse uh um
factors as well and so i'm trying to say
to everybody travel if you must and
there are often essential emotional
reasons as well as essential economic
and uh
and other reasons but try not to travel
if you don't have to because traveling
does increase your risk we know that the
more contacts you have with other people
the more likely you are to both get the
virus and to spread it so minimize
travel please and i'm asking everybody
if they're organizing meetings make sure
they're either virtual or hybrid so that
if people are unable to travel they can
still participate fully from a distance
okay it's good to talk to you doctor
thank you very much indeed for joining
us as always thank you
thank you david lloyd is with us now
hello to you doctor um lloyd where where
are you on masks and travel
oh i'm totally in favor of masks the
data is very strong that it is the
number one thing to prevent transmission
and there are one and a half million
people in the uk actually actively with
kobe at the moment so you don't know who
you're going to meet who's going to have
it
what about prime ministers walking
around hospitals without one on
well i did just see that on your clip
just before i came on i was aghast my
goodness he's broken all the rules
we still have to wear masks yeah no it's
uh
somebody didn't have a word with them
there
he rolled his sleeves up tucked his tie
and forgot his mask
exactly i mean there was a complete a
complete own goal
extraordinary
um talk to me uh you said uh did you say
one and a half million people have got
covered at the moment
yes the data i've just looked at so
there are one and a half million active
cases in the uk at the moment so numbers
are down
um but deaths are going up and one and a
half million people are coughing and
spluttering and lost their sense of
taste and smell so
that's that's what the reality is at the
moment
so they need people need to have jobs
they need to have that booster but i was
chatting to the health secretary i don't
know if you heard him um earlier on in
the program um and he was saying if you
don't have uh if you're not fully
vaccinated you're going to lose your job
as part of the nhs are you completely
behind him saying that
i'm afraid i am i'm a bit of a bit of a
i've had very strong views about this
for a very long time i really think the
nhs and social care should set an
example
uh and it should be compulsory
vaccination for everybody who works
in the health care sector who are
patient-facing and i i can relax a
little if you're if you're never going
to meet a patient honestly as a patient
if you're coming into a health setting
you should expect to be safe and one of
the things we've got to do
is to make sure that everywhere we go in
general practice in hospitals it is safe
for patients because that was a a
mistake we made at the very beginning do
you remember how
the first cases were actually picked up
in hospital so we can't have that again
and as far as booster jobs are concerned
um from the front line how's that going
it's doing very well i think the people
who who
are eligible for the boosted jobs are
the ones that are most at risk so
they're they're being very they're very
keen to get their vaccines and the
vaccine centers are working very hard to
give it
and we're stepping up our home visiting
so we can get to the very frail and the
underlying and give them their boost to
doses too so yes it's uh it's going all
right where i am and
i know the answer to this question but a
lot of our viewers won't and it's always
best to come from the doctor um can you
have your flu vaccine and uh your
booster at the same time
you can have it at the same time you can
have it an hour apart a day apart a week
apart so yes there are they're not live
vaccines so they mix at any time
okay and as far as the booster is
concerned if you need to have it you
already have been called and that's
being rolled out but what about on a
yearly basis do we have any clearer idea
yet whether we're going to have to have
another one next year
well you know way more about this than i
do okay you know you speak to all the
guys and girls who are in charge of
these things but if i had to put some
money on it i'd say we're going to have
it
every year like a flu jab so that we
just have to get protected against going
just like we get protected against the
blue viruses
and i haven't seen a flu yet i don't
know i'm just waiting for my first flu
but i haven't seen any yet which is
interesting
okay um it's good to talk to you as
always doctor thank you so much for
joining us on the program this morning
dr david lloyd thank you
always the voice of reason now
also making news for you this morning
sky news has learned the man who injured
himself and was stuck in a brecon
beacon's cave is george linnane he's
said to be doing remarkably well in
hospital after being rescued on monday
evening rescuers spent more than 50
hours getting him out of the cave after
he fell
250 metres that's a long way isn't it
goodness
the supreme court will rule this morning
on claims the internet firm google
illegally gathered the data of millions
of iphone users in the uk the company is
alleged to have bypassed the default
privacy settings on apple phones and
tracked people's online activity naughty
scientists have discovered what they
believe was the first dinosaur that
lived on greenland 214 million years ago
unofficially now named cold bone it was
medium-sized herbivore with a long neck
while its remains were first discovered
in 1994 it was only recently that
researchers realized it was an entirely
new
species more incredible pictures have
emerged overnight from the huge volcano
on the canary islands here we go
lava from uh cumbre vieja of volcano has
again reached into the sea where it
cools and forms new land for the island
of la palma it's nearly 50 days since
the first eruption scientists say nearly
two and a half thousand acres of land on
the island has so far been destroyed
dramatic pictures duke of sussex has
claimed he warned the boss of twitter
that the social media platform was
allowing a coup to be staged just hours
before protesters stormed the u.s
capitol building earlier this year let's
find out more about it should we end up
standing by in the newsroom for us this
morning uh mystic megan's husband then
knew all about it
he did kay yeah harry's version of
events he says that the night before the
capitol riots january the 6th of this
year january the 5th he was emailing
jack dorsey twitter chief exec and harry
says that he flagged up to him that this
was going to happen now harry has been
speaking as part of a panel discussion
via video chat all part of wired's
rewired conference and he was speaking
about issues relating to misinformation
online and social media hatred have a
listen to what the prince said
jack and i were
were emailing each other prior to
january the 6th where i warned him that
his platform was
allowing a coup to be staged uh that
email was sent the day before and then
it happened and i haven't heard them
since
now megan has also been speaking she has
been in new york city as part of a panel
discussion on gender pay disparity now
paid parental leave in the united states
is not mandatory and the duchess
believes that it should be this is what
she had to say
i don't see this as a political issue
frankly um look there's certainly a
precedent amongst my husband's family
and the royal family of not having any
involvement in politics but i think this
is i mean paid leave from my standpoint
is just a humanitarian issue
okay both of these appearances come just
two weeks after a data analytics firm
revealed that 70
of all the online abuse megan and harry
have suffered in the past few years has
come from just 55 accounts
okay thanks very much
fans of one of the most popular series
on netflix are about to get even more
gore here we go squid game is estimated
to have been watched a hundred and
eleven oh don't look at me million times
since it was released in september there
will now be a second series of the show
about adults who play children's games
to the death in order to win a huge cash
prize in other words it's being given
the green light
we'll talk to the secretary general of
the norwegian refugee council coming up
live from tehran as he attempts to help
the hundreds of thousands of afghan
refugees who have fled their statute
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of afghan refugees
are arriving in iran as they flee the
taliban regime in kabul officials in
tehran estimate around 4 000 cross the
border every single day let's speak to
yan eagerland secretary general of the
norwegian refugee council who is joining
us live from iran now hello to sir uh
thank you for joining us again how bad
is it for uh afghan refugees traveling
across to iran
it's terrible really the collapse inside
afghanistan is so tremendous
that
hundreds of thousands have now amassed
at the border to the neighboring
countries and one to get out over
in in here in iran
thousands and thousands of exhausted uh
you know hungry uh
people
come across these informal border
crossings because the border is
officially closed to iran and they are
fleeing hunger starvation uh
horrific conditions because there is no
real aid operation now inside of
afghanistan
because of the economic collapse we
cannot even transfer money to the banks
inside of afghanistan
what does the future hold for these
people who basically risked everything
well the future is is blick really uh
remember iran has between three and a
half and four million afghans already
here who have come over over the years
of fighting and war and misery in
afghanistan and and to put it in context
i mean iran alone has more refugees than
35 european countries there are more
people coming over the border every
day than
are at the
polish border which europe is declaring
as a continental crisis so perhaps
europe should be a little bit more
worried for these horrific root causes
of the problem which is the collapse of
the economy inside
afghanistan and there not being enough
support for the neighboring countries
then for the handful of thousands that
have now come to the border there could
be many more coming if there is not hope
uh an investment in hope in in these
areas where there are millions
uh what is the um norwegian refugee
council doing to try to help them we
just we just saw some footage of you
there so who were you going around
looking at the conditions people are
living in
well we are trying to scale up
dramatically inside afghanistan first
and foremost
we need to give hope to people that they
have a future in in afghanistan
and and and we need more money we need
the the financial system to to function
and we need a resumption of aid to the
public sector there so teachers and and
nurses and doctors etc that have been on
the international payroll for decades
and who have now been cut can get back
on international support that will do
things a bit better in
afghanistan we hope and fewer will then
give up and come here
here in iran we're also uh
trying to scale up er
more support more shelter
more uh
ability to integrate people within iran
we're
begging the iranian authorities to keep
the borders
open which europe is not by the way
so that desperate people can get shelter
can get some protection can
avoid starvation this winter
okay um it's good to talk to you doing
amazing work as always jan eagle and
thank you very much indeed for joining
us thank you
thank you
quick look at the weather